[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jim calishaw
oh he's on the road he's in tampa that's
a journalist there
dallas morning news columnist espn
around the horn contributor look at that
on the road spending some uh company
money
we're traveling for the first time in a
couple of years
didn't go to any road games last year
who has more pressure on them for the
dallas cowboys this season if i go dak
mike mccarthy
jerry jones
other um i would say dak i think
mccarthy's
pressure will come quickly
after one season
that wasn't good and on him i would say
very quickly
it doesn't help him that jerry stayed so
long with jason garrett as he did nine
and a half years i think he realizes
he had this belief in garrett as a
person because he'd known him for 25
years and it didn't work he has no such
belief with mccarthy he just brought him
here
because he was a winning coach 10 years
ago in green bay now do it again
so i think his time will be fairly quick
but
but because of the contract because of
the injury because of everything else
i think it's immediately on dac
and dak needs to have a
uh a special season
uh to to kind of
make sure make everyone feel like okay
this wasn't a this wasn't a big mistake
to
go all in with 160 million dollars on
this guy
well it's one thing to be a cute story
and then all of a sudden you get paid
and it's no longer a cute story
right jack prescott's not a cute story
anymore no he's not the overachieving
fourth round pick
uh anymore he's the guy who makes more
than every quarterback who's ever played
in the super bowl except for patrick
mahomes
and and and some people tell you his
deal is better than my homes deal so
yeah it's it's
you know whether it should be about the
money or not
it is and there is a salary cap and
while he's not
he's not killing them against the cap
now
uh he's third on the roster this year
but then it starts going up very quickly
and when we've seen other teams struggle
when a quarterback is chewing up 18 19
of the cap we've seen teams not win
because of
that uh how's morale going into this
season in dallas
i'm fine i'm fine this morning
it's ready to go we've got
four riders here and we feel good about
our predictions and our deadlines
uh but if you mean the cowboys and fans
i i i just think it's very apprehensive
because of this who they're playing if
they were playing a normal game
if they were playing
the giants who they used to open every
season against i think everybody would
feel
wonderful
but
but you have no zach martin so your best
lineman's gone again
dak hasn't played in 11 months all the
things that hang over this team
and you're playing not just a super bowl
team but a super bowl team that
a week ago the coach was calling him out
saying
i'll play the starters into the second
half we don't get this thing going
and brady comes out and goes seven for
seven and they got a touchdown it feels
like they're ready to go play the
playoffs and the cowboys didn't even
bother with the exhibition season
are you convinced the cowboys are a
playoff team
i wouldn't say convinced that's a strong
word
um
i i think it's a two-team race between
dallas and washington
i don't think there's a lot to separate
the two
i think washington is
if they can get a decent season out of
fitzpatrick
they might be the better team because
they're so much better
defensively but i but i don't know if he
can hold up for 17 games
and not fall apart as he usually has if
dallas says reasonable health
just normal nfl health i think they'll
win the division
download starts out with tampa and then
at the chargers so they could be
conceivable to be 0-2 and then i know
they have three easier games after that
but
if they start out 0-2
yeah
what do you think that
like you got to preach patience but
jerry doesn't have patience sometimes no
and it's
those easier games yeah there's three
home games coming up new york philly and
carolina well just because those teams
all had losing records i don't think
philly's very good
but i don't know what carolina's going
to do this year second year for
those coaches and all and and
and new york they beat the cowboys at
the end of last year and they got
barclays back so
if your own two
easy games are gone and all those games
start to look
tougher now if you get if you avoid owen
2
the cowboys don't play a team that had a
winning record for whatever that's worth
between tampa and kansas city in the
middle of november so they have a long
stretch against teams that were 500 or
worse
they can they can do some damage if they
can get their act together but but i
think like to your point the chargers is
a very tough
second game
at la i mean that team
[Music]
should be pretty good
somebody's going to be pretty good in
that division besides the chiefs it
might be the charges
and really all you're asking the cowboys
to do is be average on defense because
if you have an above average offense
then
are they capable of being an average
defense
they're not good at defensive tackle and
their defensive ends have not played
well or or been available
the last year or two
uh so there's a lot of excitement about
micah parsons
and a great rookie
pick and there's some excitement about
keanu neil
coming in from atlanta but they're
really just replacing
two linebackers everybody who was
excited about before jalen smith and
leighton van der ish a first round pick
and an almost first round pick so it's
like they're trying to get this
linebacker thing right
but if your defensive tackles in front
of them
are no good
and neville gallimore is not going to
play and tristan hill hasn't practiced
with the team yet
then then you just got a bunch of guys
up in front of him then you're back to
having linebackers making tackles seven
yards down the field i think tonight
tampa bay
has a great chance to run the ball a lot
and and and
do what teams did to dallas
last year and if that happens then
everybody's gonna
gonna freak out and think this thing
isn't getting better at all
always great to talk to you glad you're
traveling have fun uh tonight tim good
to be here in this wonderful setting yes
i can tell the ambiance looks really
really nice thank you bud
that's it tim callashaw only the best
for tim calishaw you know when you're
with dallas morning news and you're
traveling
uh espn also around the horn contributor
let's bring